Imagina que pudieras comprar acciones de la
granja de tu primo.
Vamos a suponer que tu primo vive en un pueblo,
tiene un establo con vacas, y tu puedes comprar
acciones de esa empresa de la misma forma
que ahora podemos invertir en “Telefónica”
o en “Google” ¿Me he vuelto loco?
¡Para nada!
Ahora mismo vais a entender a lo que me refiero.
Imagina que quieres montar una empresa ¡Una
empresa tradicional!
Por ejemplo, una explotación ganadera en
la que vas a tener unas vacas que produzcan
leche ¿Qué es lo primero que necesitas?
¡Dinero!
¿Verdad?
Tendrás que comprar el terreno, el establo
y las vacas.
Pues bien ¿De dónde puedes sacar ese dinero?
La primera opción sería ir al banco y pedir
un préstamo.
Pero eso tiene varios problemas.
Lo primero es que si ya de por sí es arriesgado
montar una empresa, con un préstamo de por
medio puedes terminar arruinado y, encima,
con una deuda que devolver.
Y todo esto, suponiendo que el señor de la
oficina esté dispuesto a darte el préstamo.
Si habéis intentado pedir un préstamo para
montar una empresa alguna vez ¡Ya sabéis
lo difícil que puede ser convencer el banco!
Así que nada… descartamos el banco.
La siguiente opción es buscarnos un inversor
de riesgo.
Ya sabéis, uno de esos que viven en Silicon
Valley.
Gente con mucho dinero dispuesta a asociarse
con jóvenes talentos ¡Quien sabe!
Igual ese pequeño establo se convierte en
un nuevo gigante agrícola.
Pero… ¿Conoces a algún inversor?
A no ser que vivas en Silicon Valley o tengas
buenas conexiones… es difícil que encuentres
a uno de esos “angel investors” de los
que tanto se habla en los periódicos.
Vale, tachamos a los bancos, tachamos a los
inversores… ¿Qué nos queda?
Tus padres… no, no tienen suficiente dinero…
Oye, tengo una idea… ¿Y si tu nueva empresa
pudiera cotizar en bolsa?
Sí, ya sabes, el mercado de valores, el sitio
donde está Telefónica, Endesa
o el Banco Santander.
Lo bueno que tiene la bolsa es que no necesitas
encontrar a un inversor millonario.
Puedes conseguir que cientos de personas particulares
compren acciones de tu empresa.
Es decir, que divides tu empresa en, vamos
a decir, 10.000 acciones y las sacas al mercado
por un precio de, vamos a poner, 10 euros
cada uno.
De esta forma, todo el mundo, independientemente
de donde viva, puede invertir en tu empresa.
A lo mejor hay un señor que vive en Albacete,
en España, que compra una acción.
Otro que vive en Cuzco, en Perú, compra 10
acciones.
De esta forma, sin tener contactos ni tener
que convencer a un banquero, puedes recaudar
el dinero que necesitas.
Sólo tienes que tener una buena idea.
¡Suena fantástico!
¿Verdad?
Bueno, hay un problema.
De entrada, para poder cotizar en la bolsa
de Madrid, tu empresa necesita contar con
un capital social de, al menos, 1.200.000
euros.
Y este es sólo uno más de los muchos requisitos
que tienes que cumplir.
Pues bien… esta es la situación en la que
estaban los chicos de la
Khokholskaya Agricultural Company.
Unos chicos que vivían en Rusia y que querían
montar una explotación ganadera ¿Y como
diríais que recaudaron el dinero?
Pues atentos a la noticia:
La empresa rusa Khokholskaya Agricultural
Company va a lanzar una ICO llamada MILKCOIN
para financiar una granja lechera.
¡Habéis oído bien!
Estos ganaderos crearon su propia criptodivisa.
Es decir, algo así como su propia versión
de Bitcoin.
Lo anunciaron en una página web y sacaron
a la venta estas nuevas monedas.
Esto es lo que se llama una Oferta Pública
de Divisas o, por sus siglas en inglés, una
ICO.
Y diréis ¿Pero por qué alguien iba a querer
comprar otra criptodivisa?
¿No tenemos bastante con BitCoin?
Bueno, a primera vista, podría parecer que
estaban comprando criptodivisas.
Pero realmente, estaban comprando algo parecido
a acciones de esta nueva empresa.
Y todo esto sin tener que pasar por la bolsa
tradicional.
Al final de este vídeo os contaremos lo que
pasó con esta empresa.
Pero lo cierto es que no es el único ejemplo.
Hay muchos, pero que muchos más…
Aunque solo el 48% de las ICOs del año pasado
cumplieron sus objetivos, las startups ya
han conseguido recaudar más de 5.600 millones
de dólares
Sí, amigos de VisualPolitik, ya hay un nuevo
método de conseguir dinero para montar una
empresa.
Y está disponible para cualquiera.
Pero esperad un momento porque no todo es
tan bonito… como os podéis imaginar, todo
esto de las ICOs suena como un paraíso para
los estafadores y la gente de mal vivir.
Así que la pregunta es… ¿De verdad podemos
fiarnos de este nuevo método de crear empresas?
¿Y qué tiene que ver Suiza en todo esto?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
MONEDAS VS TOKENS
En el año 2013, Bitcoin ya era una moneda
conocida, sobretodo en el mundo tecnológico.
En Silicon Valley ya se celebraban eventos
y mesas redondas sobre el futuro de esta divisa.
Y en una de estas mesas redondas, apareció
un señor que se llamaba J.R. WILLET.
Este hombre tenía una idea muy curiosa.
Según él, se podían crear monedas alternativas
a Bitcoin que, usando la misma tecnología,
pudieran tener reglas distintas ¿Y cómo
pagamos a los informáticos que diseñen esos
nuevos sistemas?
Pues, en lugar de buscar un inversor de riesgo,
el podía vender por unos bonos, lo que llamamos
un TOKEN, que más adelante se podrían canjear
por la nueva moneda.
Y así es como surgió la primera ICO de la
historia.
Pero antes de continuar, tenemos que hacer
un paréntesis.
Muchos os estaréis preguntando ¿Qué es
un TOKEN?
Pues bien, los TOKEN son cualquier elemento
que se pueda intercambiar en una blockchain.
Las criptomonedas son una clase de TOKEN pero
hay otras dos más.
Por un lado tenemos los que otorgan un derecho
a su portador.
Por ejemplo, este sería el caso de esos bonos
que podríamos canjear por una criptomoneda
que se creará en el futuro.
Por el otro lado, tenemos los tokens que están
basados en un activo.
Este sería el caso de las acciones de la
empresa de ganaderos rusos.
Tener uno de sus tokens equivale a tener un
porcentaje de la propiedad de su granja.
Pues bien, estas ofertas públicas de TOKENS
se pusieron de moda en el año 2014 ¿Por qué?
¿Qué pasó en el año 2014?
Pues este es el año en el que salió al mercado
la segunda criptomoneda más famosa que existe.
Ethereum: la plataforma descentralizada que
podría reemplazar a las instituciones actuales
A diferencia de Bitcoin, todos podemos saber
quién está detrás de Ethereum.
Se trata de una empresa que no sólo tiene
una criptomoneda sino que también ofrece
un sistema para que otros puedan crear sus
propios tokens.
Por ejemplo ¿Os acordáis de ese otro vídeo
en el que os contábamos que el BBVA está
usando blockchain para dar préstamos?
Pues Ethereum es la plataforma sobre la que
trabajan ¡Pero no sólo hablamos del BBVA!
En realidad son muchos los que ya están utilizando
este sistema para hacer toda clase de cosas
en blockchain.
Y una de esas cosas son las ICOS.
La fiebre Ethereum se desata: las ICO son
la moda en el mundo de la inversión tecnológica
Desde entonces, hay un montón de empresas
que se están financiando con este método.
Por ejemplo, Sirinlabs es una empresa suiza
que está a punto de sacar su propio modelo
de Smartphone.
Esta empresa ha conseguido más de 118 millones
de dólares gracias a una de las ICOs más
exitosas de la historia.
Y por supuesto, hay toda clase de empresas
de internet que están naciendo con este sistema.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque no todo es
tan bonito!
Las ICOs no tienen ninguna regulación.
Así que ya os podéis imaginar el resto.
“Cómo crear una estafa con una ICO en 5
sencillos pasos”
Y os preguntaréis ¿Pero qué diferencia
hay entre una ICO y, por ejemplo, una página
estilo Kickstarter?
Pues muy sencillo.
Cuando tú apoyas a un proyecto en Kickstarter,
no puedes vender ninguna participación.
En una ICO, sin embargo, puedes comprar tu
token o tu criptomoneda y, si sube su cotización,
venderla como si estuvieras en la bolsa.
Sólo que aquí no hay ninguna policía financiera
ni Comisión del Mercado de Valores que persiga
a los estafadores.
Así que ya os podéis imaginar la cantidad
de incautos que querían dar el pelotazo y
han terminado en la ruina.
Por ejemplo, CONFIDO era una empresa que quería
mejorar las transacciones en criptomonedas.
Todo muy bonito, muy tecnológico y muy 2.0.
Consiguieron recaudar casi 400.000 dólares
para sacar adelante este proyecto.
Y una vez conseguido ¿Qué pasó?
Que la empresa desapareció del mapa.
Y como no había ningún registro público
ni nada parecido, es casi imposible perseguir
a su dueño.
De hecho, seguro que todos habréis visto
algún anuncio que vende monedas, tokens y
no se que más, en el que te prometen ganancias
ilimitadas.
Para que os hagáis una idea, hasta el mismo
CEO de Ethereum, Vitalik Buterin, reconoce
que casi todas las ICOs son estafas.
Y como os podéis imaginar, los gobiernos
ya han empezado a actuar.
China ha prohibido tajantemente las ICOs.
En Estados Unidos parece que van a seguir
un camino similar.
Y en otros sitios como Estonia, han dicho
que vale, que se pueden hacer ICOs peeeero
los ciudadanos estonios no pueden participar.
Es algo así como decir “vale, podéis estafar
a quien queráis… menos a mi gente”.
Sin embargo, hay UN país que ha optado por
una solución intermedia.
Ni prohibirlo, ni dejarlo como está ¿Qué
tal si lo regulamos?
¿De qué país estamos hablando?
Os doy una pista.
Hablamos de el en uno de los vídeos con más
visitas de VisualPolitik… ¿Lo habéis adivinado?
Hablamos de…
SUIZA, LA CRIPTONACIÓN
¿Recordáis ese vídeo que hicimos sobre
Suiza?
Es uno de los primeros vídeos que hicimos
en este canal, allá por el año 2016 cuando
yo todavía tenía pelo.
En ese vídeo hablábamos de un cantón: el
cantón de ZUG, que es el que tiene los impuestos
más bajos de todo Suiza.
Pues ¿A que no adivináis donde tienen la
sede nuestros buenos amigos de Ethereum?
Tener a la empresa más grande de criptodivisas
en tu país significa que también tienes
a los mayores expertos en la materia.
Así que casi todas las ICOs se hacen desde
servidores suizos.
Y en seguida, el gobierno de este país se
dio cuenta de que, con o sin estafas, hablamos
de un negocio millonario.
Suiza quiere ser la capital mundial de las
criptomonedas
4 de las 10 ICOs de las ICOs más grandes
realizadas el año pasado se hicieron en Suiza,
más que en ningún otro país.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en algunas localidades
suizas, ya se pueden pagar impuestos o incluso
multas, en criptomonedas.
Zug, que ni siquiera tiene 30.000 habitantes,
es ya el hogar de más de 400 empresas de
blockchain.
Y el gobierno regional ya está empezando
a hacer pruebas para usar esta tecnología
en sus referéndums.
Ya sabéis que los referéndums suizos son
una de las bases de su sistema político.
Pues bien, ahora quieren hacerlos usando blockchain.
Y por supuesto, Suiza también quiere ser
la pionera en regular las ICOs.
La Autoridad Financiera Suiza presenta las
líneas maestras de su regulación de las
ICOs
Por ejemplo, cualquier empresa que quiera
realizar una ICO en Suiza, tendrá que hacerlo
a través de una empresa suiza.
Eso implica que tendrán que registrarse,
dar su nombre y tener una dirección física.
De esta forma, es mucho más fácil perseguir
a los terroristas o narcotraficantes que quieran
lavar su dinero.
Como os podéis imaginar, estas regulaciones
ya han surtido su efecto.
Y muchas empresas del sector se están marchando
a otros paraísos fiscales donde no hay ningún
tipo de regulaciones.
Por ejemplo, las Islas Caimán ya le están
haciendo la competencia a Suiza en lo que
a ICOs se refiere.
Pero ese es el precio a corto plazo para tener
un entorno estable.
Hablamos de un mundo que todavía necesita
mucho para ser un mercado maduro.
Pero que podría tener muchísimas posibilidades.
Mucho más allá que las estafas, el blanqueo
de dinero o los pelotazos.
Personalmente creo que la postura de Suiza
es la más inteligente.
Llega una nueva tecnología, tiene muchos
riesgos pero también muchas oportunidades.
En lugar de prohibirla o, por el contrario,
dejarla completamente libre, lo ideal es regularla.
Así nos evitamos lo malo y nos quedamos con
lo bueno.
Y por cierto, volviendo a nuestros amigos
rusos, esos que querían financiar un establo
con vacas a partir de criptomonedas… Siento
deciros que no han recaudado el dinero que
necesitaban y han tenido que cerrar el proyecto.
Por desgracia, dado que MilkCoin solo ha conseguido
un 2% de los objetivos, vamos a devolver toda
la financiación que recibimos.
Empezaremos a devolverlo el 21 de noviembre.
Gracias a todos los que nos apoyaron!
Y ahora la pregunta es ¿Creéis que otros
países seguirán el ejemplo de Suiza?
Está claro que todavía falta mucho tiempo
para que el mercado de las ICOs madure pero
¿Creéis que puede ser una auténtica revolución
financiera que permita que todo el mundo,
independientemente de dónde viva, pueda llegar
a crear su propia empresa?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y, como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribíos a VisualPolitik para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.